vientos de división soplan en el
parlamento de pakistán el presidente del
país ha aceptado disolver la asamblea
nacional en respuesta a la petición del
primer ministro en brand hand a primera
hora de la mañana el vicepresidente del
legislativo se había negado a escuchar
una moción de censura contra el primer
ministro alegando que potencias
extranjeras estaban detrás
ninguna potencia extranjera tiene
derecho a derrocar al gobierno elegido
de pakistán
por lo tanto decido que la moción de
censura viola la constitución y la
soberanía del país va en contra de las
normas y los procedimientos
el primer ministro acogió con
satisfacción la decisión
[Música]
sea derrota a un intento de cambio de
régimen un atentado contra los 22
millones de paquistaníes y una moción de
censura con una agenda extranjera que se
ha planificado en el extranjero yázpik
de
junio de yecla este giro inesperado
llega después de que la coalición lidera
por jan perdiera su mayoría en el
parlamento la semana pasada cuando
varios de sus miembros declararon que se
unirían a la oposición
sus opositores cuestionan la legitimidad
de jan y le acusan de ser el responsable
de la crisis económica del país marcado
por un desempleo e inflación récord un
debilitamiento de la moneda y una deuda
aplastante el ex campeón de criquet de
69 años acusa por su parte a la
oposición de conspirar con potencias
extranjeras para destituirlo por no
estar del lado de occidente y apoyar a
rusia y china